we're asked to prove that if the
orthocenter and centroid of a given
triangle are the same point then the
triangle is equilateral so i have a
triangle over here and we're going to
assume that it's orthocenter and
centroid are the same point and just as
a review the orthocenter is the point
where the three altitudes of a triangle
intersect and the centroid is the point
where the three medians so we can do is
we can assume that these three lines
right over here that these are both
altitudes and medians and that this
point right over here is both the
orthocenter and the centroid so if we
assume that these lines are altitudes
and that tells us that they they are
perpendicular to the opposite sides so
that is a 90 degree angle those are both
90 degree angles these are both 90
degree angles these are both 90 degree
angles and the fact that it's a centroid
means that each of these lines bisect
the opposite side so it tells us that
this length is equal to this length
that this length let me just a different
color this length is equal to that
length and it tells us that this length
this length is equal to that length and
you might also say well gee you know
each of these lines are also then the
perpendicular bisectors of each of the
sides so not only is this the
orthocenter and the centroid it is also
the circumcenter of this triangle right
over here but with that out of the way
we've kind of marked up everything that
we can assume given that this is an
orthocenter and a centroid although
there are other things other properties
of especially centroids that we know but
now let's prove that this has to be an
equilateral triangle so the first thing
that you might see and let me label some
letters here so we can refer to things a
little bit better so let's call that a
b
[Music]
c
d
e
and f and we can label the centroid
right over here g
so the first thing let's look at
triangle a f g and triangle
was e and triangle e f g so let's
compare triangle a f
triangle
a
f g let's compare that to triangle
e f g
triangle e
f g
so they definitely have one side side ef
is congruent to side af these are both
the same and we have angle efg is the
same as angle afg they're both 90
degrees and then they both clearly share
the side fg
they both share this side right over
here they both share that over there so
they have a congruent side an angle a
corresponding angle in between and
another congruent side and they're all
so congruent side congruent
corresponding angle and another
congruent corresponding side so by side
angle side these two characters are
going to be congruent
by
side angle side congruency now we can
you make that exact same argument we can
use that exact same argument to say that
all of these pairs that have that kind
of share this that both have these these
90 degree angles next to each other are
going to be congruent triangle we can by
the same exact argument we can say
triangle e d g
triangle e
d g
is going to be congruent to triangle c d
g
triangle c d g same exact thing side
angle and then we have a side right over
here and then we can use the exact same
argument for this one over here triangle
c
looks like an a
triangle c b g
is congruent to triangle a b g a
b g so that by itself is interesting
but we know that if two triangles are
congruent all of their corresponding
sides and angles are going to be
congruent so for example if we know that
the measure of this angle is blue the
corresponding angle on this triangle is
also going to have the same measure and
i'll just make it with that same blue
angle and we know if this angle right
over here is magenta the corresponding
angle on triangle afg is also going to
have that same measure and i'll just
mark it with that magenta again
now we also know from our properties of
vertical angles that whatever angle
measure afg is dgc is going to have the
same measure because they are vertical
angles
but we know whatever angle measure this
is this triangle triangle cdg
is congruent to triangle edg so
corresponding angles have to be
congruent so this angle is this magenta
measure then this angle also has to be
the magenta measure and then once again
you can say vertical angles if this is
magenta then this is also going to have
that same measure and if this has a
measure then that is also going to have
the same measure so by using a little
bit of argument of congruent triangles
corresponding angles are going to be
congruent and vertical angles we can see
that all of these inner angles right
over here are going to have to be the
same measure they're all and i'm using
that with this little magenta arc right
over there
now all of these triangles that we've
split this triangle into they all have a
90 degree angle they all have a magenta
arc so whatever's left over is going to
be 180 minus 90 minus magenta or it's
really 90 minus this magenta angle right
over here and that's what this blue
angle must be this blue angle is
essentially 90 minus the magenta angle
the blue angle is 90 minus the magenta
angle and so that blue angle must be the
third angle for all of these so once
again this blue angle is going to be 90
minus the magenta angle or 180 minus the
magenta minus the 90. so that's going to
be a blue angle if you essentially what
we're saying is if you know two angles
of a triangle it forces what the other
triangle what the other angle is going
to be we already know that all six of
these triangles have two angles in
common the 90 degree angle and the
magenta angle so they all the third
angle must be the same as well and we're
specifying that with this blue angle
this blue angle right over here and now
you see if we were to look at angle
if we were to look at angle e
e a c
so angle e
a c we see that that's just two of these
blue angles that is congruent to angle a
c e
a c e
which is just two of those blue angles
which is congruent to angle c e a
angle c e a which is once again just two
of those blue angles so we have a
triangle here where the three angles in
that triangle all are congruent so it is
an equilateral triangle it's a 60 degree
we've proven before if all three of your
angles are the same then the lengths of
all three sides are the same as well